so good afternoon
i want to first begin by thanking
ontarians for their continued vigilance
in the face of this virus
thank you for continuing to adopt the
public health measures that help to
reduce transmission
and protect yourselves your loved ones
and your communities from the severe
outcomes of covid19
it is clear that we are in the sixth
wave of this pandemic driven by the ba2
variant
in the last few weeks we have seen an
increase in the percent positivity an
upward trend in wastewater surveillance
and a rise in hospitalizations
these trends are likely to continue for
the next several weeks
but there are actions that we can take
to help manage the impact of this wave
such as layering the personal protective
measures we have adopted so well over
the last two years
even when they may not be legally
required
these include a strong recommendation to
continue wearing a well-fitted
three-layer mask or use of a medical
mask in all public indoor settings
and please continue to respect the
ongoing mask requirements that remain in
place including in hospitals in other
health care settings
long-term care homes and retirement
homes
congregate settings that provide care
and services to medically and socially
vulnerable individuals such as
children's treatment centers in shelters
public transit as well as the federal
requirements for returning international
travelers
i also want to remind ontarians that if
you test positive for covet 19 you
should continue to wear it mask at all
times
for five days following your isolation
period and avoid vulnerable people in
places like hospitals and long-term care
also from asking household and other
closed contacts of a
covid positive case are reminded that
they should be wearing a mask at all
times
and avoiding vulnerable individuals and
settings for 10 days
why will we will not be reinstating a
broad mask mandate at this time we
should all be prepared that we may need
to
resume a requirement for mask wearing in
indoor public spaces if a new variant of
concern emerges
a threat to our health care system or
potentially during the winter months
when coven 19 and other respiratory
viruses are likely to circulate again
vaccination remains one of the most
important tools to protect ourselves and
our community against the impacts of
future waves of covet 19 and it is
critical to stay up to date with your
vaccination by receiving all doses
recommended as quovet 19 transmission
increases getting a booster dose if you
are eligible and especially if you're at
high risk is very important it's your
best defense against severe illness
hospitalization and death
booster doses save lives if you've not
booked an appointment for your booster
please do so as soon as possible to
ensure you are protected against severe
outcomes of covet 19.
in addition to vaccines
antivirals are another tool the province
is using to manage covet 19 and are free
of cost
antiviral treatment including the oral
antiviral paxlovid can help to reduce
hospitalizations protect hospital
capacity and protect patients at high
risk of severe health outcomes
individuals can access
oral antiviral screening tool online at
ontario.ca
forward slash antiviral screener to help
determine if they are at high risk for
covid19 and its complications
and should be assessed for treatment
individuals who are part of high-risk
groups in what cova 19 should
immediately seek testing
and care by their
contacting their health care provider or
visiting
one of the many clinical assessment
centers across ontario
even if you don't have symptoms talk to
your primary care provider in advance to
see if the treatment is right for you in
the event that you get sick and have a
plan
health care providers can also determine
if antiviral treatment is appropriate
for patients based on individual
circumstances even if they do not belong
to one of the high-risk groups
so as i've said before the pandemic
certainly is not over we're now in the
sixth wave and the virus continues to
circulate and evolve
learning to live with covid and the
expected rise in covet cases because of
the highly transmissible ba2 variant
it is strongly recommended for all of us
to number one screen daily for any
symptoms of covet 19.
stay at home when you're sick even with
mild symptoms wear a mask especially in
indoor public settings
maintain your vaccinations a booster
dose can save your life
assess your risk before going out
antivirals now to
determine if they are right for you and
immediately seek treatment
if you become ill and are at high risk
for severe
covid infection
have a response plan
if symptoms develop know
where you can get tested
and how to contact your health care
provider
and test if you have symptoms maintain
access to ret or know where you can get
your pcr testing if you're eligible for
treatment
as we learn to manage and live with
covet 19 use the tools available to us
to continue and this will continue to
have
a critical impact on our health and
health of those living in our
communities thank you
so happy to take some questions
you said you anticipated a rise in the
virus but we're now seeing by all
accounts a hundred thousand cases or
more per day why were you not out here
talking to ontarians telling them that's
what we're seeing so those at risk can
best
assess the risk why were you not out
here talking about that
the data has been available to all
ontarians and many medical officers of
house and leaders across the health
system have been responding to a lot of
these questions we've known
that as we
remove public health measures that we
would have a rise in incidents across
ontario and hence the reason we have our
three-point plan continue to wear a mask
continue to get vaccinated ensure that
you keep up to date with your boosters
and know if
you would be eligible after discussing
it with your healthcare provider for
antivirals those three
major platforms will help ontario
through this next wave
we have thirty to forty thousand uh
treatment doses or treatment regimes of
pax love it available to ontarians and i
wanna make sure that they're used that
they're used for the most at risk for
the severe outcomes of covet 19 across
ontario and i think we've worked
robustly over the last week to ensure
that that plan is in play now so as of
tomorrow we hope uh to
announce uh of the four thousand seven
hundred pharmacies which will be
participating in the dispensing of pak
sloven we hope to continue the education
with primary care providers to ensure
they're knowledgeable about how to
prescribe it as well as work with all of
our health system partners to show to
ensure that they're knowledgeable and
how to prescribe it safely for ontarians
to prevent
this potential risk and rise in
hospitalizations in the coming weeks
public health ontario is calling for a
return to masking especially places like
schools why don't you bring masking back
in schools we've seen a big influx in
ers of young people with covet why not
mandate masks in school so it's
important to put that in perspective uh
today um there's been no significant
rise in the risk of children in the
intensive care unit so of all of ontario
2.75 million children there's two in the
intensive care unit right now on average
we're having 30 to 60 children admitted
to hospitals some of those are
incidental admissions to hospital as
well
over a one-week period so we've not seen
any significant threat to the health of
children
we do absolutely encourage children to
do all those basic steps of screening
before they go to school
use the rits those tests that are
distributed on a weekly basis to all
students across ontario to ensure you
take advantage of the immunization
strategy so i think it was 55 percent of
those 5 to 11 have taken advantage of
first doses great
response for first and second doses in
high school students but would love high
school students six months after their
last dose to get their booster as well
you said that you know that we know all
of these things but you're coming out
here saying
you know do risk assessments before you
leave which is which is much different
in fairness to just saying we need to
learn to live with kovitz so can you can
you honestly say to ontarians that as
they've been seeing these cases rise
that it's appropriate that you have not
been out here even on a
bi-weekly
basis to explain
this is where the situation is this is
where you need to be looking at it now
so the purpose of coming out today as
you know my last press conference we
told you we'd be i'd come out if there
was an issue uh the purpose today is to
remind all ontarians that they are
eligible for boosters 60 and above are
eligible for their second booster and i
got mine yesterday
it was easy to book
able to go to a local pharmacy
didn't have to wait and the pharmacy was
great and providing the vaccine quickly
to me so
over 60 please get your second booster
if you're eligible and that's roughly
five months after your last dose
as well be knowledgeable of if you're
eligible or high risk for
hospitalization to covet speak to your
health care provider and know
if you can get access to paxlovid as
well as continue to wear a mask the
purpose of coming out today is just to
reiterate yes we're in the sixth wave
yes we will see a rise in admissions to
hospital
and to the intensive care unit but as
always we have tools that can mitigate
that and prevent it for all ontarians
and
to to call once again
for people to come forward
and get immunized we've seen the rise in
numbers so we're up to 20 000 i think
yesterday got immunized with
third and fourth doses
which is brilliant but i'd love to see
more ontarians we have capacity to
immunize
higher numbers than that both through
your local pharmacies as well as through
mass immunization clinics
and and there's tremendous capacity in
the system that's not being used so
please all ontarians yes uh we're seeing
a rise uh in risk uh and that will be
for the next probably six to eight weeks
that will have a rise in risk of
transmission
and we have the tools to mitigate it
either through immunization uh if you
don't take advantage of immunization
there are oral outpatient therapies that
are provided free of charge to all
ontarians no dispensing fee
and we'll know tomorrow how many of our
pharmacies across ontario of the 4 700
are partners in uh ordering and
dispensing and that will be online as
well
so two
new messages that i'm here to provide to
ontarians to ensure that they're aware
of so with respect you didn't answer my
question is it appropriate for you to
just not be coming out here when when
there are
you know when you when you should likely
be explaining the situation is it is it
fine to just leave it up to people to be
figuring it out on their own
or or do you feel that you're not
required to be coming out here on a
daily basis or
even bi-weekly
like is this the last we're going to see
of you for another month i know well
if i have new messaging of risk to any
of the citizens of ontario i absolutely
will come out we share all of our key
messaging we did this last week with all
of our local public health agencies all
of our health system leaders as well as
our hospital leadership on the fourth
dose second booster strategy as well as
the oral antiviral it's responsibility
of all of our health care leaders across
ontario to
disseminate this
information at a community level and i'm
happy to come out on a more regular
basis if that message needs to be
promoted
do you think that if the
100 to 120 000 cases a day that some are
claiming like dr uni do you think that
that is accurate and if it is accurate
doesn't that mean that this strain is
having much less impact on ontarians if
we're at 120 000 cases a day but
hospitalizations have not gone up
dramatically well it's a really good
point i it's a testament to the the
benefit of being immunized
and you're seeing a much differential
risk of being hospitalized if you're not
immunized it's four times higher risk
to get admitted to hospital a six times
higher risk to get admitted to the
intensive care unit if you're not
immunized so what we're seeing is even
with increasing incidents uh we're
seeing uh the health
system is being protected through strong
immunity either through acquired
immunity and we estimate maybe 5.3 to 6
million ontarians have already had
just the omicron wave since december
and with these additional cases we're
not seeing the same ratios that we saw
in previous strains of
we used to have for every 100 patients
we'd have one admitted we're not seeing
that because of the benefits and
strengths of immunization so thank you
for raising that question uh it's a
testament to the power of immunization
and i really
after four to five months our
immunization benefit fades and our
antibodies decline and at this point
five months after your booster for those
60 and above i'm really asking all
ontarians to come forward and get their
booster that should protect you against
hospitalization our goal as a province
is to ensure ontarians remain healthy
and safe
and
don't need to be required to be
hospitalized don't need intensive care
and don't succumb from this virus and
the strategies that help us are
immunization that's the number one
that's helped us through this number two
is now with the 30 to 40 000 doses of
paxlovid that's an additional tool in
our armamentarian that can really
safeguard our health system or protect
ontarians on the issue of risk
assessment you've said we should be
doing our own risk assessment but
when you look at the reaction that some
people have to to cover do you think
that people even two years in know what
the actual risks are hearing stories of
young people getting infected and
seeking pax loaded even though they're
not at risk
we hear a lot of parents acting as if
schools are as dangerous as long-term
care settings do we adequately know the
risks have you established what those
risks are for the public or do we need
to be putting that out there more
instead of acting as if everyone faces
the the same level of risk well again a
great question so
i follow very close to the impact on
children in ontario i i want to ensure
that we protect our children as much as
any parent
and
i'm
following the admission rate it is a
roughly five per hundred thousand
children that have uh needed to be
hospitalized uh the mortality rate i
think we've had ten children die over
two years from covid and for the most
part and i'm sorry for any child that
has had to to succumb from this virus
and to their families but for the most
part they have had co-morbidities uh as
well
so
at a general population level the risk
to children
given that we've got significant
immunization protection
significant
very significant protection in the high
school settings is quite minimal at
present
and but we'll continue to monitor that
in case there's a strain differential
those that are most at risk for this
virus and it's very important because it
would allow you to start to understand
whether you'd be eligible
after a clinical encounter for pacslovid
are those that are over 70 we're finding
the admission rate is still very
strongly correlated to age so if you're
over 80 or 70 or 60 those individuals
have the highest admission rate so
please that's why we're here today to
talk about maintaining your immunization
maintaining your booster status for your
first booster or your second booster
and if you're 70 and over even if fully
vaccinated if you uh have a significant
risk factors you may be uh assessed by
your clinician your healthcare provider
to be uh eligible for uh antivirals the
uh from 18 to roughly 60 years of age
it would be you'd be
deemed at high risk if you had
significant core morbidity so you had a
serious neurologic condition cardiac
lung liver kidney immune deficiency hiv
or aids that would make you potentially
eligible after your clinical counter for
um
paxlovit but
in that instance
if you were fully immunized
you you'd be most likely less risk for
hospitalization so
thanks for raising that question very
important that all ontarians know what
their personal risk is um based on what
i've just mentioned have a discussion
with your health care provider in
advance if you would be eligible for
pacslovid
and have a plan to test all individuals
who would be eligible for treatment
would be eligible for any of our pcr
testing across ontario and hence the
reason we want to maintain that rapid
turnaround because you need to get
assessed within five days your initial
symptoms you need to have that test back
we will accept a positive rat test if
you've got access to that or done it at
home by the way are you still planning
on ending the mass mandate on the 27th
for long-term care homes in transit oh
we're actively reviewing it so thank you
for that question clearly the uh we
think this wave is not going to be
settling uh till the middle uh or end of
may uh and as a result we're looking at
extension for all of those high-risk
facilities anyone in those congress
settings shelters uh retirement homes
long-term care homes were
and transit absolutely considering
maintaining it our team's uh drafting it
we'll present that to government uh and
the government will make the final
decision but that to me that makes
tremendous sense to maintain it
i know you said you're recommending
well-fitting masks that people wear them
but can you be clear about why you're
not making it mandatory in a setting
like a school for example
well we are very mask friendly in
ontario we're absolutely still providing
free mass to workers the 300 000 workers
in that environment the 2.75 million
children
those are provided free of charge uh
absolutely embracing um that they can
and should be used
but
we've already responded that an
individual risk is exceptionally low for
hospitalization in that setting for
severe outcomes in that setting
and uh want to also uh continue to
promote immunization for all those
children that haven't had their booster
dose from 12 to 18 uh or who haven't got
their primary uh series from five to
eleven which is still forty percent of
children but when it comes to individual
risk there's individual risk and then
the fact that we're hearing about all
these people being knocked out of the
job and and you know productivity
falling because there's no one
there to work and do the job so so is it
a matter of individual risk versus you
know maybe trying to keep
the economic train rolling why not do it
for that purpose
so
i'm you raise a very good point i am
concerned about health care workers and
ensuring that we
have healthcare workers that can provide
care we know absent the sick um absence
has increased uh and clearly have to
monitor that so ontario health is
monitoring that very closely for us um
they are
we're looking at the
safest plans of returning workers at day
five
with negative testing either through rit
or pcr if their symptoms have completely
resolved
but i i do agree that's an ongoing
persistent issue that
in in this wave i hope all healthcare
workers are maintaining um their uh the
highest level of immunization that they
can uh and maintaining uh masking when
they're in public spaces as well because
they're so essential to us
the health workers being out sick in
pretty big numbers that we're hearing um
as well the icu numbers are going to go
up as you mentioned and we're not
bringing back any measures ahead of that
like is there a chance this is going to
affect the surgery resumption plan could
they be canceled again and like what
metrics are you aware of where that
could start happening well thank you for
that question so we're we're working
with matt anderson and his team at
ontario health
they have the same data that
the science table is looking at in terms
of modeling for ontario
they have assured me day after day
that with the current modeling they do
have capacity to care for all ontarians
i'll be straightforward it's anticipated
that we could have as high as 600 people
back in the intensive care unit uh
in the
at the peak of this
but
they have assured us that we can provide
care to those individuals um i also just
would like to intimate
it's very important to follow causative
admissions versus incidental admissions
so the causative admissions today in
ontario are only at 45 of all admissions
uh and for the intensive care unit
setting i believe it's at 65 percent
today
so when we report 180 admissions to
hospital
in the intensive care unit setting take
into consideration that 65 percent that
are causal that you may have had a motor
vehicle collision you may have had some
other medical issue
and incidentally tested positive by pcr
because pcr testing can stay positive
long after
you've recovered from covit so there's
some nuances to the data and the
projections and the modeling that we
have to review very very closely but
despite that ontario health has given us
assurance that we have capacity ontario
to care for all ontarians even with the
projection of a number like 600
individuals in the intensive care unit
it's my goal as a prevention specialist
to ensure that ontarians are aware of
that risk
four weeks from now to ensure
that they get their booster dose of
vaccine to ensure that they're aware
that there are treatments now abundance
of treatment options uh including over
40 000 doses of pax lover that we'd love
to be able to distribute and prevent
admissions to hospital and icu uh and
hence the reason i'm out today last
question
all the measures like a month ago um
we've talked about knowing there's going
to be another wave did you know it would
be this big or eventually get to 600
people in the ice we absolutely knew ba2
was going to be circulating
and
we
have seen that there is a benefit from
being immunized against ba2 there's
still strong protection levels it's just
that over time your protection levels do
fade from around 90 protection against
ba2 to 80 to 70 to 60 over time and
hence the reason i'm here today to
really promote the booster dose of the
vaccine that we announced last week
and also
in anticipation of that risk to ensure
that all ontarians are aware that there
is now much more abundance of
outpatient treatments
that i hope the 4 700 pharmacies are
willing to dispense and we'll have that
up for you tomorrow to be able to assess
and that we've done a tremendous amount
of education over the last week for all
of our primary care providers
specialists and emergency physicians to
ensure that they're aware of how to
safely prescribe this medication so that
it can be put in best use to prevent
that modeled rise
in admissions to the hospital sector
[Music]
with kingston there's very very high
rates there what what specifically is
leading to that happening
in that specific region well that's
another good good example so i think
kingston's at over 450 cases per 100 000
today and they've remained at a very
high level of
detection of cases as well as uh
infection and yet uh i believe uh today
they had nine people in hospital and 50
of them would be incidental admissions
so
roughly five admissions to hospital so
it tells you with they have one of the
highest immunization rates in the
province
that a strong immunization strategy
sprung
first dose second dose third dose fourth
though strategy can prevent the health
system impact can mitigate the negative
effects
given that our goal for all ontarians is
to minimize
morbidity mortality but also um
minimize societal disruption and and i
look i look at kfl a and and that gives
me hope uh that in the coming weeks that
we as a province can do the same also
watching peel very closely in halton
that had over 50 percent last week of
their cases uh being a ba2 and yet they
haven't had a significant impact on
their health care system their their
admissions to hospital have remained
relatively stable and their capacity to
care for ontarians is stable so you know
these are examples they're early waves
of ba2
and very high community transmission but
because of the robust protection that we
as ontarians have all taken advantage of
we're not seeing the health system
impact that could have occurred so
please if
if this is the last question i had three
messages to come up with today please
stay up to date with your boosters
boosters can save your lives
if you haven't taken advantage of our
immunization strategy in ontario please
consider getting your first or second
dose it's never too late please also
realize if you're in the high-risk group
for a severe outcome from covet 19.
realize now that there's therapies
discuss that with your health care
provider in advance have a test and
treat strategy that you can put in play
if you develop symptoms of covenanting
these can all mitigate this ba2 wave
that is upon us
and protect our own health our family's
health but also our health system thank
you thanks everyone we gotta get going
thank you thanks everyone